hey guys tell to go and i'm justine nice
to see you or meet you if you're new
here on my youtube channel this is a
show called ask IJ where you guys ask me
questions and I answer that I heard I
just seem to spot a hen way
just can't wait
so it's going to make this episode
different from some of my previous ones
is I took all of my questions from
tumblr let's uh let's start these
questions before I start talking about
something else and the first question is
I eat your cookies is saying which parts
at tumblr define particularly scary
weird creepy odd there's definitely some
times that I have somehow managed to get
into some very creepy parts of toddler
my favorite thing is the animated gifs
that people make it they're so funny
especially some of you guys who pull
clips from people's YouTube videos oh my
god or you can love it Robertson Naru
definitely didn't pronounce your name
correctly was your favorite multiplayer
mode of black ops 2 and have you played
the gun game my favorite mode is
definitely free-for-all because you see
somebody you should have they moved
their dead most of the time if I'm
having a good game dead be advised
hostile hunter killer drone in fact dead
I'm dead
I haven't played some of the gun games
which are pretty fun but really
free-for-all is it's my thing country by
heart is asking me if I'm artistic at
all they still love to draw and paint
and do all kinds of stuff and I'm kind
of thinking of starting a new show to
sort of show some more of my attempt at
being artistic again I probably if my
mom could find some of my old artistic
endeavors for you guys when I was little
oh my goodness
Jack is wondering what my first phone
was I didn't get a phone until I was
probably 18 although my little sister
actually had a cell phone before me
because I hated talking on the phone
still to this day I absolutely hate
talking about gives me complete absolute
anxiety I've actually removed the phone
from my home screen so you can't even
find it my sister I had to make a phone
call the other day she picks up my phone
she's like where the heck is your phone
I haven't hidden in between folders and
folders and folders so basically I don't
talk to the phone change throughout time
since where do you think you'll be in 20
years you know what I don't even know I
don't know I'm gonna be tomorrow so
asking me where to be in 20 years I
don't know with the help of a fantastic
iPhone application I can see what I'm
gonna look like 20 or more years
do watch revenge on ABC I not watch the
show yet but a lot of my friends are
watching it everybody keeps talking
about it so it's probably going to be
one that I'm definitely gonna start
watching I hate to watching shows when
there are in the first seasons because I
get so involved to get invested and I
love the characters and then guess what
happens they can select Michael Munson
arrow what my iPhone's wallpaper is kind
of like the the mac os/x background
without one of them all to match I
usually end up using all of the standard
wallpapers on my computers and my phones
I don't know why it's kind of boring but
that's just how I roll
you can get started any YouTube show
channel which would you choose this is a
hard one I've always wanted to be in a
Freddie Wong video because I want to
fake shoot things I want to do some
crazy stunts I also would love to do
another fun video with rhett and Link I
haven't done a video with them in a very
very long time also definitely would
love to do a video with jenna Marbles
except I would probably have to ask you
maybe limit the video to maybe 1 or 2 F
words per video so that's possible oh my
god this is great
what did I roll up to and what was
missing I bowled up do the thing with my
fila missing what am i cool I can pull
up to the single my silly missus pull up
to the scene with my cellar missing pull
up to the sea with my silly missing seen
the ceiling was missing
Oh drains radical losers wants to know
about any tips for someone who wants to
start making videos honestly my tip to
you is just started doing it when I
first started making videos I was
seriously using the iSight camera on my
macbook nowadays that camera is
perfectly fine it's freaking 1080p you
can even use your iPhone you can use any
phone just start making the videos post
them and learn from your mistakes I'm
still learning for my mistakes and when
you start shooting and editing yourself
you learn about the most annoying things
that you do I hate editing my own videos
because there's so many things that I do
I just want to be like stop it would you
ever consider coloring your hair a crazy
color definitely probably wouldn't do a
crazy color but I do want to dye it a
little darker all one color and then
just kind of see what happens from there
I mean this is pretty much my natural
color now the
are still a little too blonde coz the
blonde is just kind of is growing out I
don't know I don't know I don't know
and that's actually all the questions
that I have hmm all right thank you guys
so much for all of your questions next
week I think I'm gonna be taking some
questions for Facebook so be sure to
follow me on Facebook home slash
iJustine anyway I'll see you guys soon
so don't think you subscribe check out
the rest of my YouTube channels and if
you're really really bored follow me
everywhere on the Internet as iJustine
I'll see you later
[Music]